hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast empirical data on the path to
genomic medicine I am Judy Aurora
collaborates and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we try
to answer as many questions as we can
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems view and
you're hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left I would now like
to introduce today's speaker rod would
see green MD MPH dr. Greene is a medical
geneticist and physician scientist who
directs the genomes to people research
program in translational genomics and
health outcomes in the division of
genetics and freedom and Women's
Hospital the Broad Institute and Harvard
Medical School dr. green sees patients
and conduct sand curricle research
around the medical behavioral and
economic outcomes associated with the
implementation of genomic medicine he
currently co-chairs the steering
committees of both the clinical
sequencing exploratory research program
with 18 NIH grants and over 300
investigators and the newborn sequencing
in genomic medicine program with for NIH
grants and over 100 investigators in is
a co-investigator in the recently
awarded partners project as a member of
the electronic medical records and
genomics network dr. Greene is associate
director for research of Partners
HealthCare personalized medicine and a
member of the executive committee for
the partners biobank I will now turn it
over to dr. Greene from his presentation
thanks very much Judy it's a pleasure to
be here talking to all you folks who are
watching this on your computers i'm
going to give you an overview today of
the kind of research that I do and
really excited to talk to you about this
research but I show you some data that
we've collected in the past and what
whets your appetite for some of the data
that's coming out of the midstate
project maybe see project which are
taking place right now now you know we
do sort of rely on our academics to try
to give fair and balanced attention to
data so it's important you know my
disclosures and here they are and i'll
be talking about some of the things that
industry is very interested in in terms
of personalized medicine and
personalized and precision genomics so
the starting point for where my work
begins is with the patient and there's
all this extraordinary biological
research going on all this extraordinary
computational research going on in
genomics but there is also the last mile
problem in other words what are we going
to do when we get information that we
learned from genomics research and how
we're going to use it with patients when
is it going to be ready for prime time
and how are we going to decide what are
the impacts for doing this the project
the program that I run is really a
program in looking at the medical
behavioral and economic outcomes of its
now when we talk about genomics and
genomic testing we're really talking
about multiple things we're talking
about enhanced newborn screening the
idea that at the beginning of their life
a newborn baby could have their entire
genome sequence this could serve as a
blueprint for them for the rest of their
life we're talking about the diagnosis
of rare condition which of course is
already underway using exome and genome
sequencing we're talking about
preconception screaming is it really
something we're going to lead to random
chance if you have a recessive carrier
trait and your
may be with somebody else and you're
going to leave a chance whether to know
if they are carrying a recessive carrier
trade as well in an era where we can
actually detect that we're talking about
prenatal screening and diagnosis and of
course ni PT has had an extraordinary
rise in popularity rightly we're talking
about something medical genetics has
always done which is the pre-symptomatic
testing of families with genetic
diagnosis easily Huntington's disease or
BRCA or putting myopathy we've got a new
era coming many people are interested in
the notion of predisposition screening
using genome sequencing that's going to
be a hot and controversial area because
it really depends on what you are
interested in the narrative of
prevention alone or whether you really
are demanding evidence to back that up
of course there's an entire enormous
area of poor targeted therapies with
cancer and pharmacogenomics that I'm
really going to speak very little about
today and then there is the thing we
often forget about when we're talking
about personal genomics which is the
degree to which all of this research
uncovers pathophysiology of disease in
ways that can give us clues to new
treatments and new strategies for
treating so I think we're you know we're
we've got a lot of opportunities to
think about these things and we're only
going to cover a few of them today and
these are the few that I've been most
interested in over the last 15 years and
thinking about how genomics is going to
impact the medical behavioral and
economic aspects of patient care so I
started in the area of Alzheimer's
disease I was very interested in whether
a risk variant for Alzheimer's disease
was an appropriate thing to share with
family members who were asking about you
know all my genetics colleagues at that
time said oh no no no you can't possibly
be wanting to disclose it actually it's
still controversial to this day even
though we've now done a lot of research
in this and research that we did in this
area is called
reveal study risk evaluation and
education for Alzheimer's disease we've
actually had this funded for many years
many iterations and it arises out of the
a pony variant a very common variation
we're about twenty percent of the
population has one copy of this little
putting them at about three times the
risk of developing Alzheimer's disease
and another couple of percentiles have
to copy simple 44 which put them at
about 15 or 30 times the risk of
developing Alzheimer's disease now when
we first started this there were
families asking hey can I and I learned
this about myself I'd like to know there
was a lot of pushback because this was
not them and it still is not an
actionable conditions of prevention is a
proven treatment to keep you from
getting Alzheimer's disease if you
discover that you had this very but yet
people still wanted to know so I'm not
going to take you through all the work
we did over over the past 15 years but
we published over 34 manuscripts with
the data from the reveal study i will
mention our sort of flagship paper we're
in which we reported the results of a
randomized clinical trial in which we
randomized people to get their apoe
genotype or not to get the regular
genotype and then we compared how they
did on all sorts of outcomes of
understanding emotional impact anxiety
distress and so forth and along in the
short of it is well we were able to see
a signal of sorts it certainly made a
difference whether he found out you were
positive or before negative we were
unable to demonstrate a group change in
anxiety or distress it was really
clinically significant in other words
people did surprisingly well with this
information now remember these are
people who elected to get this
information so it's not like we were
forcing this on me so that was quite an
interesting observation and we've been
able to replicate
in several additional trials in addition
we were among the first to show that
people were trying to do things with
this information so they were trying to
do more exercise newer medications the
vitamins things I thought would help
even though there was no proven
treatment for Alzheimer's disease and we
also showed that people were more likely
to report they were going to purchase
long term care insurance now this has
been talked about for a long time the
notion that learning you're at risk for
something would put you at increased
risk or what would predispose you to buy
more insurance if you found your
increased risk or less insurance if you
found you at less risk insurance
companies call this adverse selection
and they're quite rightfully concerned
about it because if clients know
something the insurance company doesn't
know then they can buy a lot of
insurance and essentially put the
insurance company on business now we'll
get back to this when we talk a little
later about Gina but what this suggests
is that there is a real potential for
adverse selection in a world where lots
of people are learning about their
genetic risk now with a lot of
investigators but particularly with kirk
christiansen which own here we've
published quite a lot around the reveal
study here's a few of the headlines from
our different papers in case you're
interested all of these can be found on
our website and we are continuing to
publish at one slide to show you some
some of the data from our most recent
publication where we use the clinical
trial methodology to add a single
additional piece of information to the
risk information about Alzheimer's
disease so what we did is one arm not
just the risk that they were adults I'm
a disease based on the rape believe the
other arm got some risks about their
heart disease potentially also based on
a belief because there's just
pleiotropic effective
we found some fascinating results it
turned out that getting one additional
piece of information made you less
anxious and more likely to act on the
results in terms of some sort of
lifestyle improving exercise diet and so
forth so you got the same information
about your risk amount of Alzheimer's
disease but adding an additional piece
of information about heart disease even
if it meant you were increased risk for
heart disease reduced your anxiety and
distress from the first piece of
information really strange something
about piling on the information maybe
that seems to reduce the valence of any
particular piece of it it's really hard
to interpret in but maybe this is a clue
to why several hundreds of thousands of
a million people have gotten risk
information of direct-to-consumer
genetic testing for scores and disease
risks and really haven't had much much
distress event in fascinating towards
the rollout direct-to-consumer genetic
testing well speaking of that we saw
this phenomenon coming it got launched
as you know in 2007 and gradually built
up steam with the first couple of
companies out there and we were very
curious to take what we learned in a
real study and study sort of the
multiple risk factors that were being
disclosed by the companies that were
promoting direct-to-consumer genetic
testing so we got funded by NIH to do
this and in 2010 launched a very
carefully crafted survey with two
companies as you can see here and we
were able to examine people's opinions
and attitudes before they got themselves
and I tested shortly after they got
their results and six months later and
again we've got quite a few papers
coming out about this it stirred a lot
of controversy as you know the FDA
ordered 23andme the leading company at
that time to cease operations in
2013 we were among the few people who
wrote that maybe this was overly
cautious because it already been seven
hundred thousand individuals who
received these results that had already
been quite a few research studies of the
cust customers and we really hadn't seen
evidence of harm the FDA has since we
allowed that particular company to start
selling recessive carrier traits again
and there wouldn't on trying to get
regulatory approval or they're in kind
of portfolios but we started studying
this and again I'll just flash some
titles up because we publish quite a lot
about this we've looked at how confident
people are about their knowledge I'll
show you some data about what they do
with the results and interesting that
when people are adopted how to perceive
their direct consumer results of course
they don't have them in histories and
how they interact with their primary
care doctors and just to zoom in on a
little bit of this one let's ask some
questions that are commonly asked about
personal genomic testing particularly
direct-to-consumer testing so what is it
that they're most interested in and our
research suggested no surprise here
they're very curious they're interested
in their health and interested in your
ancestry and one thing we documented
that really hadn't been talked about
much is kind of obvious when you think
about it there they're interested in if
there are explanations or something they
already have so for instance you've got
diabetes you go first and look at the
diabetes here's a little paper on this
and some of the data we saw so if you
already had a diagnosis you can see on
the right of heart disease you were more
interested in the heart disease genetics
when if you didn't already have a
diagnosis same thing on the far left you
can see if you already had ulcerative
colitis you were much more interested in
the genetics of ulcerative colitis than
you were he didn't already have it now
one level this makes perfect sense look
we're interested in ourselves and if you
have something
and kind of go and report that but if
another level in a product that's being
pitched as a predictive risk product
this is sort of profoundly irrational
right because you know if you already
have it why would you be looking at your
genetic risk variants for whether or not
you can give so that was pretty
interesting you know there's been a lot
of controversy around a dtc arena about
whether the algorithms for risk
estimation are correctly calculating are
they appropriate and our answer that is
both yes and no we took a hard look at
these algorithms the senior Arthur
Sicily Anselm's and we came up with the
same observation than others have made
that in fact the three original
companies who got into the direct
consumer market actually computed their
summary algorithms in different ways and
some of those ways we didn't think were
completely accurate but we also came up
with pretty obvious explanations for why
they did so and one of the most obvious
explanations was that one company would
take 10 different monitors to make their
calculation or another would only take
six or another week 8 14 so you know
some of this is pretty easily remedy if
the companies agreed on how many markers
that were going to use the new
estimations turns out though that my
first blush if perfect concordance were
along the diagonal lines there you can
see that the different companies were
quite some discordant in terms of their
estimations for risk now at a very
important question is whether customers
understand what it is that they've been
told and the answer to this is mostly
yes we were able to look in this paper
at
question we actually created models for
or sort of dummy results and asked the
customers specific questions about
interpreter so they weren't biased by
their own results and if 100 is a
perfect score you can see there are
these some of these scenarios people
were scoring 60 683 5918 293 9860 374
we're not perfect but they are
consistently better than average and for
many of these answers they're above
ninety percent so yes these are early
adopters these are not necessarily the
kinds of people who will be doing
direct-to-consumer genetic testing in a
world where millions of people are doing
it every day but so far pretty good
comprehension one of the big concerns
was if you hit people pharmacogenomic
information will they run off and change
their own prescription medications based
on us and our answer is no they don't
seem to be doing that I preliminary data
on this I'm currently under review
suggests that less than one percent of
people who could have changed the
medication will do so without medical
consultation so it just doesn't look
like they're going to run out in and do
this on their own and you know a really
interesting sort of subtle question is
does this whole experience change their
perception of their own risk you know if
it doesn't even change the perception of
their risk then probably not going to
have much impact on their behavior so we
were able to show that we think it does
so let's take the common complex
variance for cancerous these are not
been doing single gene cancer
predisposition variants these are more g
was type variants for cancer that were
provided in direct consumer testing and
it turns out that as you can see on the
left if you even
have a negative family history if you
learn that you're at elevated risk then
indeed it changes your perception see
that triangle goes up higher than the
squid interestingly if you've got a
positive family history for cancer the
amount of increase in your perception of
your own risk is even hundred so
something about the personal template
that you walk into this experience with
pushes your risk perception higher same
sort of thing over here on the right
with one cancer accepted here if you've
gotta hire a personal risk of lung
cancer because your smoker you will also
boost be increasing your perception when
you get an elevated risk message from
the company well there's been some very
interesting arguments of both here in
the United States in published essays
and also this is a common refrain in
Europe that personalized genomics in
general is a bad idea because it's going
to stimulate all sorts of medical
spinning it's unnecessary and our
results suggest this isn't exactly the
case so far we found we found that the
number one and really only significant
variable that determines whether people
take the results and go out and get a
bunch of medical tests is whether they
got a bunch of medical testing year
before they got there direct-to-consumer
testing in other words if you're a
person who likes to get tested this will
be another opportunity for you get
tested but it did not seem to be related
to the number that you got back from the
direct consumer company so it was almost
impervious to the message you are
getting not enough this is good news or
bad news I mean it's good news in the
sense it's not costing the medical care
system a lot of money it may be bad news
if you're trying to argue that the
direct-to-consumer genetic testing has a
real-world impact
on surveillance and Prevention of
disease and importantly these customers
do anything with their results now
there's been this narrative throughout
personalized genomics partly in response
to the dearth of data of really good
data in in this arena and embed by
Cochrane reviews of the data that's out
there and when people get genetic risk
information particularly common complex
risk information they just don't do
anything it doesn't have any impact on
their behavior now that may be partly
true in part because the haters really
tough to change under any circumstances
but we do see that people are reporting
some changes in their lifestyle these
results in fact about thirty percent of
the customers a new survey reported that
they improve their exercise or diet now
we don't know if they actually did it or
not and we don't know the true cause our
friend here maybe they got their genetic
testing a sort of stimulated them to
make these lifestyle changes maybe they
were making lifestyle changes anyway and
as part of that resolved they went out
and got direct-to-consumer genetic
testing it's a little hard to untangle
teeth but it doesn't seem to suggest
that people are doing less which is one
of the concerns you know the idea that
people would find Eric's lightly the
lower genetic risk for diabetes for
example and then they say well then I
don't have to worry about my guy I don't
go out to meet whatever so that kind of
false reassurance is a concern in direct
to consumer Janet testing one from the
FDA and it's a little hard to untangle
here but our evidence does not suggest
that this is a big concern and and
finally just out to try to address the
question is there any biological
evidence health benefit
after any kind of common complex was
variants are used to stratify risk and
yes the first time we had some data
although this information was not
presented as part of a
direct-to-consumer genetic testing
company was common complex risk
information for heart disease was
presented as part of a trial at Mayo
Clinic senior author ikkaku low in which
this was demonstrated to you can see the
graph on the on the bottom the people
who learned about their genetic risk
coronary heart disease as part of the
medical process with their doctors ended
up its lower LDL cholesterol now this
was sort of a combination of perhaps the
patient and the doctor working together
you don't know exactly whether it was
specifying woman staten medication
better compliance or some combination
vote but this was a carefully controlled
study and it did the first time
demonstrate this kind of biological
effect so that's pretty exciting so
finally what happens when personal
genomics consumers share the results
with their primary care providers well
as you might imagine all hell breaks
loose it's a pretty scary prospect
because primary care Doc's are not well
prepared for this information lots been
written about this not quite that
terrible we published on this and turns
out that a lot of people don't bother
because the results don't seem
worthwhile to share what they just don't
get around to it and a large percentage
35-percent extremely satisfied with
their primary care doc so some of them
out there doing something right when it
comes to talking to their patients about
this but a surprisingly high percentage
eighteen percent were very unsatisfied
if you're interested there's some great
anecdotes in this article so you can go
out and get it if you'd like times when
the primary care doc you know get
dramatic things like taking an important
throwing it in trash can there's a huge
spectrum of reactions to this from the
primary care doc so really interesting
stories about how they respond to this
but you know I wanted to show you some
of those because we recently published a
lot of those results but I'm
particularly excited right now to be
telling you a little bit about two
trials which are ongoing and in which
results are just starting to emerge and
these are trials that are hoping to
answer the question of how we're going
to use X own genome sequencing in
everyday practice immense now let me
reiterate that we are already using
Excel burn genome sequencing for the
diagnosis of rare diseases most of you
heard these incredible stories pretty
unusual but a children like Nick Walker
here not terribly debilitating your
fatal disease and were diagnosed and
even treated on the basis of genome
sequencing that's still the rarity but
we are seeing that when you get
mysterious diseases that cannot be
diagnosed by any other means you can
find a molecular diagnosis and sumner
between about twenty and fifty percent
of these depending on the presentation
yessir canaan and so forth that's pretty
incredible you've got these diseases
where there's been a diagnostic Odyssey
particularly in children the parents
have taken them from one doctor to
another and sometimes a great expense
great heartache and you actually can
make a molecular diagnosis leaving the
family of the burden of not knowing
sometimes providing the opportunity for
reproductive planning so this is pretty
huge but as this has become more common
we've been facing the problem and we
offered
of incident appliance as many of you
know I got to help lead the ACMG working
group artisanal finest now in 2013 we
published this and we recommended 24
conditions 56 genes we looked for and
recorded whenever you're doing clinical
sequencing and for the most practices
permeated clinical practice pretty well
it's not a requirement patients can opt
out of the entire group but almost all
patients well over ninety percent have
opted in to receive these and of course
many sites like Baylor are not only
returning this minimalist of secondary
families but also returning a much
richer list of other findings there was
a fair amount of debate about this
there's some debate that printing mine
and the collide questions about what's
the right analogy here you know if you
get a chest x-ray word for something
that's looking at your ribs and they see
a shadow in your lungs they're clearly
going to report that they're not going
to ask you if you want it they're not
going to warn you ahead of time they
might find something that's secondary
but on the other hand people are printed
out and I think they have legitimate
point that we like to appear where we
were showing people into whole body
scanners and we were finding all sorts
of stuff and sending us on wild goose
chases sometimes getting biopsies even
surgeries that didn't need to be done
and that sometimes put people in harm's
way so you know we don't do it so much
anymore we don't we don't recommend or
conduct whole body scans on helping
people just looking for whether they can
find so I think this is still going to
be played out of because in clinical
sequencing there's a lot more you can
look for them but at least there is a
short list of mostly dominant conditions
that we think are medically important
because you can do something about them
and this form the basis for a dialogue
about incidental findings the next part
I want to talk about is the Met
community is the med seek project and
the Betsey project that arises out of
the notion that sequencing is going to
become so ubiquitous that all of us who
practice medicine are going to need to
use including people who aren't don't
have very much training in genetics and
that there's so much information how do
we create a process they can present
this information to a practicing doctor
in a way that doesn't require them to be
a super specialist and we designed it
this is kind of both a a
proof-of-concept study and a randomized
clinical trial reduce the pilot study
the randomized clinical trial we took
two groups of patients patients who had
a cardiomyopathy patients who had
basically generally good health and we
randomized each group to receive
standard of care or an entire whole
genome sequence with a full report and
then we just studied the heck out of all
sorts of outcomes Medical Outcomes
perceptual outcomes behavioral outcomes
economic outcomes even outcomes even the
doctors were enrolled that we studied
the doctors reaction to this as well so
our results are going to starting to
come out on this I don't have a whole
lot to show you but i will show you some
interesting preliminary things we wrote
this little article last year about Gina
the Genetic Information
non-discrimination Act because so many
of the patients we were approaching were
still terrified about genetic
discrimination now you know we have a
very structured consent form and he told
them that they were protected for
certain categories from Gina but when
they learn that other categories such as
disability and life insurance and long
term care insurance were not protected
by Gina they pretty hesitant about this
so we actually found that of the people
who sat down with
genetic counselors can consent that's
it's already a big cut there about
twenty eight percent of them declined
and we were pointed that the insurance
discrimination was the reason that they
declined so it's you know maybe that's
maybe Gina is one of the reasons we got
anybody at all but it's a little
disappointing given that one of the
stated goals of gina was to reassure
people so they can get genetic testing
they can participate in genetic research
I think that if we really are going to
do genetic testing in for example
presence precision medicine initiative
we're really going to be creating all
these data and giving them back to
people and perhaps giving them back as
well to their to their doctors and
having influence the medical records
we're going to need to address this even
more with Wesley Regina has done the
other thing that we've worked on
intensively in medicine and this has
been led by Heidi Rehm who is one of our
co pis and Mitzi project and who runs
the laboratory for molecular medicine is
the careful curation for variance I will
go through the side of detail except to
say that as most of you know who r
involved with their interation there is
a question of this that can be done in a
scalable way with computer
interpretation and that involves
frequency filters filtering against
databases and so forth but at the end of
the pipeline a lot of stuff comes out
it's still wrong it requires someone
with a lot of knowledge and a lot of
experience to go and look up those
papers and read those papers and review
those papers and it's also something
that's going to change every six to 12
months because so much new gate is being
added that the interpretation of genomes
is not something that can be sort of
fixed in stone and done once so we're
trying to address these questions and
next I'm really making a lot of careful
thought around the very pipeline when
you
read about this in lavaca mclaughlin at
our article from 2014 we published on
this and also by building intimacy
protocol erie evaluation and reporting
component we also did something I was
quite proud of that a lot of commercial
groups have adopted now not as we came
up with a single page summary of the
entire complexity of a whole genome and
you can see here that we gotta portion
at the top talks about monogenic disease
risk a portion next to that the toxin
carrier risk portion and promo code
genomic variation and then in ours
apportion on blood groups has been read
by guerlain at our institution and Jason
Massey pictured here has published on
this and other parts of messy project
showing how this was designed what our
logic and rationale learn how it's being
used with primary care doctors in men
sequin well here's some preliminary
results if you look now not just the 56
genes but you look at 4,600 disease
associated genes you'll find some pretty
interesting things even with just the
first hundred people to be sequence so
in the first hundred people we sequence
92 and ninety-two percent of them are
carrying at least one recessive
character trait probably no surprise to
you you know we all know that we're kind
of out there carrying an average of two
or three or four days but nice to see
that validated on noise but do something
pretty surprising that twenty percent of
risk group of people were carrying a
variant for a dominantly inherited or
two recessive traits that put them at
risk for the appearance of a genetic
phenotype this is not counting the
people who were sequence for cause for
their cardio mouth taking those out of
the picture these are unanticipated or
secondary findings
and we included in here some of the
recessive some of the the US is leaning
pathogenic I'll show you in a minute
some of the examples but still that's a
pretty remarkably high percentage now it
obviously doesn't mean the twenty
percent are going to get these diseases
but what percentage either have some
unrecognized form of this condition or
are going to develop a condition in the
future and that's question of course a
critically important question the
question we just don't know the answer
to you here are some of the actual
variants that we found in our
participants and you can see that
they're listed first with the pathogenic
ones and the likely pathogenic ones and
then variants of uncertain significance
favoring pathogenic so we're more sure
about the ones at the top less sure
about the ones at the bottom but
nonetheless you can see that they span a
gamut of rare conditions and we're
currently in the process avoiding back
to these patients and targeting our
phenotyping to understand did we miss
something did there are all their
doctors miss simple is there any
subclinical version of this condition
that they're walking around with or is
it completely non penetrant so that's
going to be really interesting and I'll
have some of those results to bring back
to you on a future date well of course
one of the huge questions as being asked
by scientists my policy makers by
reimburse yrs by companies seeking to
invest in the space is what's the
clinical utility of sequencing problem
people you know is this going to be
something that everyone should do is
this going to be something that no one
should do if they don't actually have a
complaint
and we were able to explore that in
Mitzi project because we are actually
sequencing healthy people and sending
the results back to their doctors and
what we're seeing is that primary care
doctors do order things they like to
order things in filming responsible to
order things and so you can see in this
first case a likely pathogenic variant
was discovered from Romano Award
syndrome cardiac rhythm disorder and the
primary care doc it's an extra EKG and
refers them to a cardiovascular
geneticist perfectly reasonable but yes
this is going to increase costs now the
question it's harder for us to answer in
the small study that doesn't go for the
years is how how much you value is any
given patient and get out of this kind
of encounter and we're going to try to
get some clues to that in the med seed
project but it's going to take Roger
numbers and longer follow-up to remain
answer the question sort of the
cost-effectiveness 101 here of course
what we're trying to sort out in this is
whether there is enough benefit from
early disease prevention and detection
that balances out any harmful medical
interventions that could accrue more
tests you do or medications you start
more potential for harm is moreover
what's the cost of doing is and through
this we can estimate cost effectiveness
and kirk christiansen and Jason Massey
in our group are working on models to
actually estimate this for primary care
actually started publishing some of that
you can see in this preliminary data the
doctors are taking more time and they
are spending more money and vote for one
of the first times ever we're
documenting what these costs will be in
people who are healthy but in Veronica's
sequence
so you know if we really were imagining
a thought experiment to answer this
question of penetrance we'd sort of say
well it's sequence a whole bunch of
people and then let's follow them for a
long period of time and see what kind of
conditions they develop now that's a
very expensive and very elaborate test
study but we do have some studies we can
take advantage of so we turn to the
framingham heart study where people
subset of people have in sequence and
those subset had been followed for an
average 20 views when you kind of in
your like that and ask well let's just
take me CMG 56 how many of those people
and was 460 two of them in framingham
did we find pathogenic variant were the
ACMG 56 jeans okay 462 people and we
found one percent or five of them look
on that top row all ACM jeans you'll see
that we observed five of them to have a
pathogenic variant in an AC mg g then
when we look at their clinical features
over 20 years we saw the form of very
spot eighty percent I developed a
clinical feature that was consistent
with the genetic variant that had been
discovered so that's eighty percent well
the question really is how does that
compare the rest of the population is
not carrying the indentation and we
estimated through modeling that it was
dramatically different over 20 years
eighty percent versus twelve percent
this is a pretty small sample size so we
replicated the entire exercise in a much
larger and now an african-american
Jackson artisan and we did this at over
3,000 people and found that 26 before
carrying pathogenic mutations and of
those twenty-seven percent have the
clinical features
condition where all are we expected it
to be fewer because this is basically
cross-sectional study but still our
models and found a statistically
significant difference between those
with mutation and those without the
mutation so this is preliminary data
it's not yet published you can see the
individuals at the bottom all approved
contribute tremendous worthiness and
that it's under review but in public
domain because it's been presented in
national meetings we're very excited
about these findings and hopefully with
your ex of course if you believe that
screening is advantageous and adults I
know we need to do probably be done as
well then you probably those who do
would say well why not started at a
younger age even Francis Collins it
something's like somebody's talks by
saying majan a day when every baby has
their book of life printed out at the
beginning of their life to be useful for
the help as we've improved and indeed
sequencing newborn babies is something
that gets talked about a lot but not
going so much because there are a lot of
troubling issues around this do you
return a piece of information that
suggests an adult onset condition if you
do you're really taking away the choice
of that baby once they reach the age in
jority to choose that for themselves do
you tell a parent something that is not
completely kind of trick about the baby
even they say they want to know I mean
look your baby has a mutation for a
childhood of going set fatal cancer but
we don't know what the probability is
that they will get that cancer now you
tell somebody that recipe is that really
doing them any good or is that just
injecting distress and concern into the
parent-child relationship nonetheless
it's talked about so much and there are
health systems and
companies springing up to do this it's
really important to do it and study it
in a very controlled manner like a lot
of safety precautions and that's what
we've done in baby seat crunching we
launch this project again very similar
to med sleep with two groups a group of
very sick NICU babies and a group of
healthy newborns the NICU babies aren't
so controversial there's a lot of people
who are saying you know what sequencing
NICU babies is getting more and more
necessary because so many of them have
something genetic or not but it's still
not standard of care so fair game for
trial sequencing healthy newborns is
really novel and troubles a lot of
people we hope we're doing it in a very
responsible very thoughtful manner you
know people want it so at least they say
that we did this preliminary study where
we went on the on the new baby ward on
the working world and we asked parents
hey would you like to have your new baby
sequins and a remarkable eighteen
percent was extremely interested
twenty-eight percent very interested in
about thirty six percent someone so if
you believe those numbers there's a big
market for this out but it's all in the
framing we tried to ask that question in
a pretty mutual way but when we started
doing this and we had a certain script
that had been agreed upon with the RV
where we may have had emphasized more
some of the downside of this then we're
finding that of the close to 500 first
people who agreed to meet with the study
team great to hear about the study this
wasn't the people we walked in the room
they said get out this is the people who
said oh sure I'll meet with you that
sounds interesting only about ten
percent 48 out of 495 actually enrolled
and most of the ones who decline were
concerned some what about the burden of
study but also very concerned
proud of learning bad news or insurance
discrimination or their baby as the baby
pool so once again we're finding that
coupling is that the promise of genomic
medicine is not necessarily is
convincing to people when you present it
in the context of some of the downside
this is a very tricky area to be working
in we sometimes feel that we're sailing
between the Scylla of the FDA and the
correctness of the IRB and both of them
with the best of intentions are
struggling to make sense of this along
with us and finally I'll end up with
asking what are people like you those of
you who are listening I'm sure some of
you are getting your own genome sequence
some of you would like to get your
genome sequence and we're very
interested in what you're doing with the
results so we want something a
consortium called people seek consortium
it's a bunch of groups that are out
there doing their own thing getting
people sequence and giving them the
results basically healthy people this is
George church's PDP it's Lee hoods
pioneer 100 Eric shots Mount Sinai
wellness study Thomas Cass keys genome
projects a new group from Nevada of now
group from and eat a several other
groups that are participating in this
and of course the group is done most of
this the alumina understand your genome
programs all these groups in addition to
med seek our sequencing healthy
individuals and giving them the results
back but none of them were systematic
for studying what we've done is pulled
all these groups together and we're
systematically studying how people
understand the results and what they're
doing
so just give you one little teaser about
the results that are coming out of this
in our first sixty or so people from UNG
alone found out that the health care
professionals who get their genome
sequence react a lot differently from
the non healthcare professionals turns
out that the seventy-two percent of the
non healthcare professionals had
discussed these results with the doctors
doctors being doctors a lot fewer of
them said that they had done so when it
came to whether your genetic information
should be part of your medical record
the non healthcare professionals were a
lot more sanguine about that and when it
came to people having a right to access
their own genetic information without
going through medical professional the
healthcare professionals were a lot more
conservative about that so lots of cool
results are we coming out of people
sneaking in the months and years ahead I
want to acknowledge the kind of teams
that it takes to run these very comfy
complicated studies particularly a med
seat project and the baby seat project
there are an extraordinary number of
really important people that are
involved particularly our project
leadership are there on the slide and
extending to our external advisory board
on consultants and our safety monitoring
group and the very same thing is true of
the baby seat project the BBC project is
ringing run co-led by Alan bags and
boston children's hospital and is
equally directed by scientists at
Brigham and Women's Hospital in Boston
Children's Hospital as the sick babies
come from Boston Children's and the
world ratings are currently coming from
Brigham and Women's so we thank all
those co-investigators and really
appreciate that the science likenesses
team science there has to be thought of
and appreciated and credit as such I
also want to thank all of you out there
in your tax dollars for NIH funding and
of course to thank NIH particularly
NHGRI that's funded our see Sir
consortium immense écran co-funded baby
project with the child institute and
many of the other plants that I've
worked on both as a principal
investigator and there's a
co-investigator with all these talented
friends and colleagues so this is the
core group our genomes two people
research group we're really fun group
here in Boston if you're thinking of
pursuing a research career in this area
you know someone who is please get in
contact with us we're very interested in
students and trainees we have slots from
postdocs we have slots or ND fellows and
we're very interested in helping
trainees progress in this area here's
all the contact information for me and
for our group if you do Twitter please
follow us at both Robert see green NGOs
to people and to sum up we're interested
in providing clinical sequencing for
healthy individuals and we're getting
ready to launch this as a clinical
product you're at Brigham Women's
Hospital we are continuing to hire
genetic counselors and project managers
with a strong background in genetics and
genomics and we are seeking a scientific
investment by this we mean collaborators
and trainees to support our coolest new
ideas but of course if you'd like to
donate we're up for national I want to
thank everybody for listening today and
I really appreciate your time hope you
enjoyed this and hope you'll contact us
with any questions and I'm looking
forward to any questions that might be
raised thank you for that informative
presentation before it gets started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can our first
question is what are the main questions
that your research seeks to answer
well I think the overarching question is
how do we use genomics in inside and
outside of the practice of medicine I
believe it I'd I certainly don't believe
that that the practice of medicine is
the only channel through which we're
going to receive information about
ourselves I think it's pretty clear that
they're going to be many channels
commercial channels direct-to-consumer
channels hybrid channels where you know
you purchase something from a company
and you have a company doctor or who's
there providing minimal oversight
channels where you can get it on your
own but there's somebody there's sort of
a safety net of someone to reach out oh
and of course conventional channels
where you go to a doctor or a other
health care provider and and a
particular test is ordered and
interpreted so I kind of think of it
like you know broadcast TV moving to
cable TV you lots and lots more choices
sort of think about that in the genomics
world and really in the medical world at
large and i think that the research we
do in genomes to people is really asking
given that this area is exploded given
that there's so many ways for people to
get information potential ways for them
to understand and this understanding
what's safe and what's known what's
beneficial in what's known what's
cost-effective and what's not and i
think that that's a as a set of the
beginning we're right on the cutting
edge of the last mile genomics is
generating so much cool information so
much potentially life-saving information
where can we apply it fastest soonest
cheapest safest to help tell people so
those are the sort of questions that I
think Kyle we're focused on
what have we learned about how
individuals we ought to learning about
their genetic risks well that's a huge
and pregnant question how people react
to learning about their genetic risk has
been something that geneticists and
genetic counselors and ethicist and
legal scholars have been very very
concerned about it and I don't blame
them I as a geneticist I've SAT across
from someone who you're killing has just
received a positive message that they
are going to that they have a positive
vacation for Huntington disease and
they're going to develop the disease
that they lived long enough this is a
devastating devastating piece of
information on the other hand the number
of conditions where you have a purely
deterministic untreatable devastating
condition like honey bees are pretty few
what we really have discovered in
genetics is a enormous panoply of risk
variation and an enormous complexity of
things which influence that risk and
which interact with the environment and
in this context I think we need to move
away from being as concerned as we lose
to me about disclosing genetic risk
information now I'm not cavalier about
this I don't think that we should have
to press the Sun people don't want it I
don't think that we should be cavalier
about some emotional impacts that could
accrue as people learn risks degree
thing walk into the interaction with a
particular vulnerability but I do think
that the practice of medicine has for
all time involved a certain amount of
risk assessment and risk prediction and
if done correctly and thoughtfully and
with appropriate
education genomics I think can be folded
into that in a way that is not
exceptional eyes genomic information I
think exceptional ization of so much
genomic information has taken us partway
down the wrong path and I'm excited that
you know a lot of disruptive models out
there for using genomic information that
are I think normalizing this again
sometimes whether we like it or not in
genetics how many doctors responding to
having genetic information available to
their patients or should say on their
patients well primary care Doc's are
completely unprepared for results of a
whole genome sequence and yet we got it
doesn't know them to volunteer
participate in the next seat project and
we got a few hours of training not
treating a genomic so much but training
on how to read report see our our
philosophy here is you don't have to be
a nuclear physicist to read an MRI
report you don't have to be a chemist to
read a chemistry lab report you actually
put the burden on the left side to write
a coherent important to make it clear
what's going on and a little bit of
training on the doctor side and we're
finding that these primary care Doc's
are doing pretty well now have they made
a few mistakes sure we're actually all
you recording all their interactions as
they disclose these results and they're
not perfect but we're getting some real
insights into the first wave of primary
care doctors without a genetic counselor
you're sitting there talking to their
patients about their whole genome
sequence it's pretty exciting stuff to
read the transcripts of moods now having
said that with these admittedly early
adopters I will say that our research
paper on primary care docs and
direct-to-consumer genetic testing made
it clear that there's also a lot of
reluctance a lot of inertia a lot of
fear
a little bit of hostility out there
among regular doctors to all this
newfangled genomic stuff so many primary
care Doc's are very practical this isn't
going to give me something that I can
specifically do this patient upon me I
don't want to hear them when the other
hand others seem to take this as really
interesting information as a teachable
moment to better Council their patients
to talk to them about both genetic and
environmental influences so I think it's
a little bit of a Rorschach on the
doctor himself or herself as to how they
respond to this but big picture there's
no question that most people in American
medicine are not yet prepared for this I
think they need to be I think it's going
to be a massive training effort for all
our specialty organizations to release
get us up to a certain level of
competency in dealing with genomics you
know what if we don't do that I think
people are just going to find ways
around the medical profession to get
this information I think that would be
really unfortunate what are the most
pressing issues facing the field of
medical genetics pace days well remember
that early slide that I gave that show
you know medical genetics is really so
many different things it's really
different when you're talking to a woman
there's a high-risk pregnancy and an
ultrasound abnormality about her
situation versus a healthy individual
who's getting a pathogenic variant in a
cardiac rhythm abnormalities so you know
apples and oranges all across the board
and lots of other route as well but I I
do think that the question of penetrance
is probably the most pressing unknown
that's preventing us from scientifically
taking more
edge of the genome of course penetrance
means the probability if you have
mutation you either have we're going to
develop the disease in question so for
example we know that the RCA ones
perhaps as high as seventy percent
country in women with a family history
we think that it's pretty highly
penetrant maybe fifty sixty percent
penetrate even in one without a family
history we're not sure and probably know
the most about that one so all of these
genes including many of the ACMG 56
genes that we recommended be disclosed
we did settle with a certain amount of
uncertainty about the countries
particularly in families that don't have
strong family history that's a real
limitation now on how to use this
information out even talked about so I'd
say penetrance is the number one problem
for me in implementing genomic medicine
okay we have time for one last question
how do you predict genetic genetic data
will be used in the next ten years well
many many folks including my friend
George church has has said that genomic
technologies today are going to be like
personal computer technologies in a few
years certainly live in a decade we're
not even going to be able to imagine how
we function then in turn in an eight a
day without interacting with a genome
perhaps I are express / proteome on the
tableau of our biome this is the sort of
bio everything is going to be part and
parcel of our daily life in the same way
that electronic computers or smartphones
are at this moment I'm I know if it's
going to be that ubiquitous but I do
believe that within ten years it's going
to be very much a part of everything
doing the practice of medicine and quite
a bit more a part of the day-to-day life
of all of this so I feel really lucky to
be in this area it's kind of a growth
area I feel really fortunate to be at
this fantastic institution of Brigham
Women's Hospital road in harvard medical
school and I feel really pleased to have
a chance to speak to you today thanks
again for watching and look forward to
speaking to you again in the future when
I can bring you more data from then seek
and maybe see I would like to once again
thank dr. Greene for his presentation
before you go do you have any final
comments to share with us today no I
think we've covered a lot of ground and
I'm really delighted to have justice
degree thanks so much you thank you
again today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through November
11 2016 you'll receive an email from lab
roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to for that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event see you next time goodbye